one of the stranger but more powerful
discoveries of psychotherapy is that the
average baby firmly believes it has two
mothers mother one is kind she comes
when it calls she gives it milk as soon
as it needs it she's sweet natured and
generous wondrous and eminently
deserving of love but then there's
another mother a far more challenging
and terrifying proposition who we can
call mother too and she sometimes
doesn't give baby milk exactly when it
wants it she occasionally fails to
interpret its needs she can misjudge the
temperature of the water at bath time
she has friends who come around and
distract her and a phone that Rings she
gets it wrong babies are creatures of
intense emotion to Mother one the baby
directs deep and boundless love to
mother to it gives pure and unalloyed
hate it wants to scream chew her up and
put her in the been forever and ever
with time and by now the baby might be a
toddler a shocking realization is made
despite evidence to the contrary it
emerges that mothers one and two are in
fact the very same person the mother who
can at one moment be completely
delightful and gratifying is it appears
the same mother who at another moment is
profoundly enraging and innovating this
definitely isn't common sense and it
takes a good long while to digest such a
sobering notion indeed it's such a
wounding and complicated thought
Psychotherapy tells us that many of us
don't manage to accept it properly until
late on in adulthood after we've caused
ourselves and others a lot of pain for
years we can be inveterate dividers like
babies we also decide that good and bad
pleasing and frustrating cannot exist
within the heart of a single decent
person in the early days of a
relationship we are certain that we've
met love one a delightful being who
tells us kind things on our initial
dates someone with whom we might go to
Venice who understands us completely
whom we want to marry and set up home
with but then somewhere along the way
this person seems to give birth to a
body double someone with their exact
height and width with the same eyes and
hairstyle who occasionally sneaks into
the room while we're not looking and
whom we might turn lover too and this
person is a much less enchanting Soul
they leave their wet tow on the bathroom
floor they have three annoying friends
they don't respect our Hobbies they say
really a bit too often for a while just
like an enraged baby we decide that the
best place for l two is at the bottom of
the bin which will mean letting go of
their twin as well but on the way to
telling them it's over we may be struck
by a more nuanced ambivalent yet
ultimately livable idea but lovers one
and two are in spite of all the signs to
the contrary the same person under the
influence of different moods and
circumstances and that good and bad
stand in a complex relationship within
anyone and that perfect people do not
exist these are sad thoughts in many
ways tragic ones even and we may kick
against them for an understandably long
time hopping from one partner to another
while we do so but eventually we may
learn to apply to other people the same
degree of pessimistic generosity we give
ourselves we might allow them to be
though we dear wish they weren't
sometimes as wicked flawed disappointing
and silly as we know we are we can
eventually recognize that there is
something yet more important than
finding a lover who never lets us down
that is a lover who exists a lover who
is real